you wanted to be a movie star absolutely
that was your plan yeah it was at the
time eddie murphy was my my favorite
star
and star wars was my favorite movie
and i i saw myself as being eddie murphy
in star wars oh wow you know uh so for
me the the shot at independence day and
the shot at men in black i think star
wars opened up my love for science
fiction so that's why
i made so many films in that in that
genre and i love there's a story about
you i think you you were doing fresh
prince so you were known and you went to
a planet hollywood opening yes yes i
went to it was uh planet hollywood was a
a restaurant i don't know did you did it
yeah so planet hollywood it was when
they were opening and it was in in uh
australia you know and you know i was
asked to to come to the opening i went
and it was arnold schwarzenegger it was
uh ah yeah there was like what i call
them in the book the magi you know the
three the three wise men and they were
standing and talking and
i walked into the crowd and i was like
hey guys i'm sorry
listen
i i want to do what you're doing i want
to be the biggest movie star in in the
world and i know if anybody can tell me
how to do it you guys
can and they you know i kind of looked
at one another and then
i i guess in like the secret movie star
language they communicated that arnold
was going to answer me and
you know and uh
arnold said if you're going to be a
movie star
the movies can't only be successful in
america
you've got to go to every country in the
world you have to think of yourself as a
politician running for the job of
biggest movie star in the world
[Music]